yesterday I watched three men die as one
man sneezed in a room full of blood and
she had had light today three more men
go in cheat mobs in each other's lives
in their hands yesterday I watched a man
I admired gunned down for leaving a rose
for a girl whose life was tattered by
trauma she never deserved today she
doesn't remember and three halls down I
can hear her screaming yesterday I
watched a group of soldiers go down
fighting against the corpses of comrades
who died before them today we test
another sample this time on children
yesterday I watched five men and women
gunned down
and abandoned a factory that one cares
about today it happens again and again
every 11 seconds forever yesterday I
watched a man sit comfortably in a nice
armchair sipping scotch and laughing as
he ordered a woman to simply stop
breathing today
he gets the day off work detail for a
good behavior yesterday I watched
hundreds of men and women in orange
jumpsuits herded like animals into empty
rooms that filled with gas and fire
today hundreds more are told they have a
chance for a lighter sentence and a
chance to serve their country yesterday
I watched the world nearly die in a
thousand thousand terrible place
sometimes we would have time to scream
today I'm alive to write about it one
happy endings [ __ ] you you're a life to
read it god help us all
secure contain protect
you